- We were just talking about Graceland.
You live in Tennessee, right?
I do, I do I'm in Nashville now?
- Have you ever been to Graceland?
- Yeah.
- I have.
As a matter of fact, I went
when I was on the show, we went,
the show "Idol", when we went to
we went to Graceland
because it was the week.
- Oh.
That was the week I got
voted off doing Elvis.
- No.
- And it was, it was the
week I was most proud of.
I did "Suspicious Minds".
I'm like, I know this jam.
And, and yeah, that was
that was so I got to meet
Priscilla and Lisa with me.
- Wow
And it was, it was an
incredible experience.
Yeah.
- Oh my God I missed that
- I've been there a couple times
- and we're actually getting
ready to perform there.
They have a venue there now.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
- Oh, wow.
See, I gotta go check it.
I live like in Nashville, for
like I don't know 12 years.
- I can't believe you've never been
- I never, I can't
I work a lot, but I just, yeah
never made it there and
I don't know how I didn't
but I love that you live Nashville.
It's such a, it's such a great
place to like work and live.
- Yes.
- It's a good place for musicians
- Yes. Very much so
- of all different genres.
I feel like.
- Yeah.
I have so many friends there
and we never see each other.
- Oh My God.
- That's the biggest joke here for me.
- Yeah.
Everybody's like, what are
you doing in your off time?
And I was like, oh, that's a cute term.
- Yeah, I'm in bed by nine o'clock.
- Yeah.
- Easy.
- Because when you're
a parent, you're like
I get home from work.
And then I parent.
- Exactly
- So that's what I do, I'm so cool.